>> JOINING US NOW IS OUR PANEL.
KIRSTEN, YOU USED TO WORK AS AN
ANALYST AT FOX NEWS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO TODAY'S
ANNOUNCEMENT?
>> I THINK IT'S STUNNING BECAUSE
BILL O'REILLY WAS FOX NEWS, IT
WAS UNTHINKABLE THAT HE WOULD
EVER LEAVE THERE EXCEPT UNDER
HIS OWN TERMS.
I DID HIS SHOW REGULARLY FOR A
LONG TIME.
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT AN
INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED EARLIER
IN MY CAREER, HE GOT MARGARET'S
NAME WRONG AND HE SAID HEY GET
MY NAME RIGHT, HE SAID OH, I'M
SORRY, THERE'S A LOT OF BLONDS
IN THIS OPERATION, I CAN'T KEEP
YOU STRAIGHT.
MEGIN KELLEY IS COMING UP AND
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE BLOND
NAMES, AND HE SAID THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BLONDNESS.
I SAID I DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I SAID IF YOU MEAN HE'S
HYPO
HYPOCRISY.
I WAS CALLED TO MY BOSS'S
OFFICE, THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN
DO, WE'RE SORRY THIS HAPPENED TO
YOU, I COMPLAINED TO ROGER AILS,
HE SAID THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN
DO, IT'S BILL, HE'S A JERK, NO
ONE LIKES HIM.
HE SAID YOU KNOW, BILL LIKES TO
PUT UP DIRTY PICTURES AND ASK
PRETTY GIRLS TO TALK ABOUT THEM.
AND THEN HE SAID, YOU KNOW, WHAT
AM I GOING TO DO?
I DON'T LIKE HIM, BUT HE MAKES
SO MUCH MONEY THERE'S NOTHING I
CAN DO.
>> WHO WAS THIS?
>> ROGER AILS.
THIS WAS THE CULTURE, BILL WAS
JUST TOO BIG AND THERE WAS
NOTHING YOU COULD DO ABOUT IT.
THIS IS AN ELECTION YEAR, THIS
IS THE BIGGEST SHOW AT FOX.
AND THEN ABOUT THREE YEARS
LATER, I WENT BACK AND I SAID,
LOOK, I'M WILLING TO GIVE THIS
ANOTHER TRY.
I CAME BACK ON THE SHOW AND WE
ACTUALLY NEVER HAD ANOTHER
PROBLEM.
WE ACTUALLY ENDED UP HAVING
QUITE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
IT JUST SPOKE VOLUMES THAT I HAD
TO COMPLETELY HANDLE IT ON